this week we've got come on mom
tattoo fail I think I know that oh no
and burger with coke
you know tattoo feels but think you
tweeted for sure did it's gotta be the
Ariana Oh beau I gotta get back on
Twitter do you guys all do it we got so
fun I like Twitter burial ground mild
now you have businesses you're taking
care of so nice of you you've never
admitted that you're a [ __ ] boss ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude can I show you this
delicious banana brandy good boys and
then it's got the wetness of the banana
David David's on my team I'll just give
you the selfies I have to bust nuts in
it to keep it together that's why it's
boys what's been eating a lot of sugars
I know you did it but you said it he
wasn't even there he was on his rider
retreat okay I just was lonely oh I'm so
pretty today
for some reason I imagine Tiger slobber
wait where did we're not even thought
we're talking out of articles detective
slobber on my cake I put through church
together and then he sits on the he
stands on the counter and he I give him
stuff to do so that he's doing stuff oh
I like it when he cries he back in
looking suplex and powerbomb him so bad
dude I know you need actually he likes
that stuff I bad I launch that ball in
the air and he likes it firing out of a
cannon reading they would do it better
nails the other day I straight throw
that for my kids pie I gotta have
Asperger's
[Laughter]
as money got worse cuz of me I know we
all know alright first story so the mom
are a mom from Georgia she accidently
Georgia yeah she accidentally donated
this travel mug which belonged to her
son mm-hmm but she didn't realize that
there were there was $6,500 inside of it
it was his hiding place in a mug so what
happened here is they remove the lid oh
this is what I look like
yes oh why was she donated why are you
going through my [ __ ] mom oh I hate it
when your parents go through your [ __ ]
man I can't relate [ __ ] your mom
never went through your [ __ ] my
grandparents would through my diary once
I [ __ ] lost my should do my
grandparents my English gave it to my
uncle and Auntie to read to them they
just opened up in life that's a family
my dad found my leads - anything when I
come back from work we're talking about
this and I know that's code for I'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out it is not
talking so I ran away from home I packed
my bags at the mmediately I left dude
that just shows the severity of this
house in Sweden a week that's a long
time my mom started calling she's like
she knows where my best friend is
showing that she cares and loves for you
yeah when you're around but it was a
lure to come back homes like a [ __ ] oh
yeah well it would be probably more
relaxed turn into a big disaster cuz the
reason why I went home is on the last
day of school I got kicked out while I
was gone so it was just like it was one
thing led to another so too many things
come so now it was like the last day
when I called her I also call him from
school she does that work I'm like yeah
but you also have to come to school
right now because I'm yes Bell yes oh
you just go went to school when you were
running away with the cops arrested us
cuz we're at the house and because it
was supposed to be
hours they brought us to the school also
you didn't get your ass beat for the
weed you like to ask before the getting
kicked out of school
no actually I forgetting kicked when I
got kicked out of squad and get my ass
beat that day because I think was too
bad oh they're so disappear so when I
felt that and if you give it up or if
you give enough time their anger will
eventually chill like just try it out
like let's try it out guys if you run
away and it's only been one day dirt it
gets like this it goes like they get
angrier and angrier and angrier and then
they were like yeah then it starts to
worry so like give it about two weeks
each pair is yeah alright I hear like I
hear tyka and I'm like God my ovaries go
crazy and then I hear Bart stories and
like I'm gonna go home i OD on birth
control
yeah there it is alright so this story
here no she's gonna remove her ovaries
sorry so what happened here is that her
son sold his car but he was also in the
process of moving so he thought that he
would have this money safe in his
parents house and so that's when the mom
just decided I'm gonna donate a whole
bunch of stuff I don't want anymore and
then they took it to it we saw the Mauri
condo
I know it's fire nothing sparks joy
anymore dude for real yeah there's a
battered old man at this point man just
I'm throwing away everything right now
dude oh I saw your sweet hell like
Amazon just makes you buy dumb [ __ ] all
the time same I have so much stupid [ __ ]
for no reason but we've been doing this
forever and we knew this it's not a
mystery yeah you even tweeted like a few
years back you're like it's my money I
could spend it how I want and then
that's the picture the stupidest [ __ ]
I've ever seen you've exactly I throw
away so much stuff dude I had a
collection of tiny wooden spoons tiny
why do you have those they're like this
big and I found it and I couldn't find
the reason why I got it you're probably
gonna give the today yeah it was a gift
to me you asked for you know when I was
at a hotel I actually left it but I
found a Tabasco thing literally like
this big that's all bro
would catch up in little mustard and I
was like wait little buster that side
that individual serving size but they
were all the fat ketchup and mustard
right no it was like the act like the
size of a life-size one but it's small
this big and it came in three of them
and you didn't bring it back I left it
at the hotel terrible friend
but you grabbed it for me yeah I mean
yeah what count that's all I know you
saw that the basket one but I never saw
the three yeah okay so let me keep
concedes on you these three so she said
that now she feels she's the worst mom
in the world because she accidentally
donated she didn't know oh because it
ended up going to a goodwill they priced
it it went up on the Shelf and someone
bought it so now they're like pleading
like please do the right thing and
return the mug no one's gonna there's
some good people out there dude I
remember when I was working I'm not one
of them good people that go to Goodwill
though yeah I'm kind of goodwill and pie
[ __ ] me too yeah but you did that for
sketches no like in high school like
second hand [ __ ] it was pretty tight of
it you got some cool [ __ ] dude
so you in heist - judge you in high
school you bought the Levi's jacket
bottom ugh I opened it and there's seven
G's in there I would I would because my
mom ingrained in my head you wouldn't go
seven G's if I go back to Goodwill I'll
buy the whole store I would have been
like you're smart it is drug dealers
money and I'm gonna keep it off the
streets or did a good thing no they're
too lazy there's there's security
cameras now you never know so anyway
this is a family but that was Mia - oh
man I bet they have a golden retriever
yeah they do
they just trot them out he's actually
there's two of I'm sitting there they
got a bowl and then a boat was it the
older son yeah so 27 year old son
everybody's middle-eastern except for
the young kid yeah the only different oh
[ __ ] sorry that's the mom yeah oh they
do look very they look like they could
be Italian or something it looks like it
looks like they're related and then
they're related yeah so it's like that
oh yeah maybe it's like a divorced or
maybe yeah stuff kids not stars like the
genetics got randomized yeah where did
his eyebrows come from the sons I rose I
don't know
anyway put on to our next story all
right Bernard
Ariana Grande got a tattoo on her hand
and its kanji letters oh yeah yeah so I
hope she got it don't watch fingers look
like hot dogs dude it looks like a dog
yeah it looks fake it looks like the
Japanese sausage the fish cake the fish
cake sausage like they edited out all
the wrinkles I feel like your hands
would look like that cuz they're so
smooth but I have lions and wrinkles but
hers is like maybe they had a shadow
rubberband here : maybe yeah
that's true so individually this means
seven and this means ring but together
it means Barbie's a small little boy
what were you what does she wanted to me
I knew her new single seven rings but
she wanted it in kanji and she didn't
realize putting it together changes the
meaning yeah but it's also gonna come
off if it's on this side I thought well
that's what she says that because it's
in the palm that that's that area your
body it always yeah it sheds a lot yeah
bachchi on her I don't know if that's
hibachi see it's you say that she
shooting [ __ ] [ __ ] in but okay so here's
the [ __ ] thing my best friend Amy her
tattoo ours is the same exact tattoo
artists edit that and he posted that
photo and he's getting so much [ __ ] like
people are giving him [ __ ] as if it was
his fault the best whatever they want
yeah printed it out and say can you do
this for it's not his fault so people
are talking [ __ ] like oh and I'm done
it's on his follies why is he Japanese
no he the [ __ ] would he know that Lee
it's not his job to go and [ __ ] read
up on what the hell she wanted like
ariana comes to you for a tattoo you
give her what the [ __ ] it's ariana
grande doing that 13 year old girl wants
a tattoo you give it to her dude yeah
god damn it people are giving him [ __ ]
and by the way like it doesn't work like
English where you could just type in the
words and then figure out what it means
it does not work that one translator
like so in reality she's missing three
characters in between the two characters
did she just type that in [ __ ] Google
she did she down I did that's what my
tattoo is grammatically incorrect I type
this into Google Translate for Japanese
words it's supposed to say fear no one
but I think it ends up saying like I'm
afraid of everybody my mom called him
out on that because we we she was like
don't use Google Translate guys she
fought his leg and she's like that's a
funny-looking thing to say and he's like
what is he afraid of everybody fear or
some [ __ ] did you find out until his mom
pointing it out I think so cuz no one
else knows you know what everybody fear
is actually pretty good too because it
could and everybody because it teaches
you to be humble yeah you know which I
actually actually I [ __ ] hate it dude
I'm sorry Tara is a terrible idea just
go with that story from now on that's a
funny
it's a funny tattoo does not even
grammatically correct but I tried though
when I was I tried it looks cool I tried
Google translating like 20 Chinese
things to test it now I'm like okay cool
so it works but it's just I've been the
one Japanese thing night well that's
what I'm saying like like when other
people get like Asian like specifically
like Chinese there are so many Chinese
like symbols that even Chinese people
don't know how many there are
yeah because they do simplify I think
you're talking about tattoos right now
cuz you shut online of my dad's head to
universe is [ __ ] funny dude your dad
bacon ever dude you should never talk
about the happy bacon that [ __ ] was yeah
they're big fans of smoked pork that was
the first time I actually ever
downloaded the pick stitch app just so I
could attach the two things together
just to put bacon
I mean daughter and child and father
okay yeah [ __ ] oh I was like [ __ ]
just so happy about my tattoo and then
also Dave I came notification David so
calmly commented on your on your on your
photo and it ruined everything
okay so mine is bad which is father and
he has calling on his arm which together
is father and child and then David David
put it together bacon yeah piece of [ __ ]
you should be [ __ ] of all people of
all people but I'm saying it the tattoo
got better dude okay it did get a little
piece of bacon test you don't mean who
you guys should just done that dude
there's a full-on Mexican tats you
sleeve and a piece of bacon yeah but
they ask you people love pork they do
what is it got a me pass but tell me
because doesn't mean back on yeah bad
when I got my Japanese had to I would
through like six different Japanese
people that's that's what you're
supposed to do yeah well I mean in in
translation it don't look at it like you
know what the [ __ ] we had a bad guy like
a bad bad person well good oh you don't
end up like mine do you know what it is
it a Chinese character do you know what
it means on G it's it's similar because
Chinese people see my tattoo move it and
they like they know how to read it
the kanji is very similar yeah cuz
they're saying that Ariana's tattoo it
translates to seven wheels in Chinese oh
yeah chillin yeah I knew I recognized it
her fingers just freak me out what is
her palm pink what her fingers have
jaundice true yeah well I mean she just
got it so it's like oh yeah that makes
sense that makes sense just stupid is
what it says did yes did you post it on
Instagram and a whole bunch of people
started yeah I'm like oh my god did she
really get that and then she just
deleted it and then she ended up saying
never delete [ __ ] she ended up saying
that it's too late too late so she
tweeted her hurt like [ __ ] still looks
tight I would have liked I wouldn't have
lasted one more symbol laughed my ass
off but this spot also peels a ton and
won't last so if I miss it enough I'll
offered through the whole thing next
time also huge amount of tiny barbecue
girls she joked that's tight yeah just
go what they just rolled that's not bad
a minutes that foods bomb yeah and at
least it's here
it's not like on her face or you know
it's like here she just can't high five
people for the rest of her life
yeah at least it is a concert Japanese
people chant high five Japanese people
come on I mean it could have been worse
in history it could have been like
[ __ ] or something else
picnic dog [ __ ] our last story
oh this pop-up burger restaurant in
Australia shreya strong that try ID buy
dried up no getting some heat on social
media marwene getting some heat could
it's a burger place in there cookie like
it may perhaps dictum real jokes you're
really good at those yeah I just I'm
gonna be a pun person you are honey
thank you all right so this burger spot
is called pablo escobar's what's wrong
with that side of cocaine with every
pretty bad with every burger right how
about oh right oh [ __ ] no a line of coke
and I fold the dollar bets [ __ ] fun
okay it's bad to glorify this guy please
I don't know it isn't powdered sugar
it's like a thousand dollar burger then
it has like Pablo Escobar and a hundred
dollar bill but this sense of humor it's
cute because we have a restaurant here
in downtown
that's called mal oh wait what it's like
a it's a Chinese restaurant but it's
like communist theme
oh that please the Communists hotpot we
know there's one in this it's like a
restaurant in on Melrose - there's a
year maybe they opened up another one
but yeah that one - Wow
but like they also give you a little
baggie of coke with their friends
assault that's funny that's kind of
adorable that's [ __ ] hilarious I
think it would it would have been
probably got less heat if they mixed it
up with different dictators if it wasn't
just Pablo Escobar that is just very
like drug lords yeah I'm sorry different
like drug lords and [ __ ] they have
chopped all drinks like it was a hooded
Denzel Washington play in that blue
thing I like a blue thing or entertained
it no blue
Heisenberg er hmm oh very nice
Eisenberger that would have been better
blue magic blue magic you mean I mean
American hustle American yeah a gangster
gangster American Idol I forgot his name
but he was a big-time heroin American
what I reckon gangster Harlem drug
dealer Frank Lucas Frank I don't know
Mexican food Lucas there you go you're
welcome no thanks there you go oh yeah
so a lot of people are saying like wow
you're glorifying drug use yes they were
like no there now other people it's a
parody you stupid [ __ ] so crazy man what
Frank Lucas could be a hot dog because
of Breaking Bad you have any idea how
much I want to smell this smell sell
meth smell metha people's taping the
line of coke it's garlic flour um so
anyway yeah so people are saying like
wow what if we use Nazis for this and
buff up I actually wouldn't mind that
yeah they put a little nice white stick
on top of my burger like a stamp they
branded it on the burger eat the whole
thing really fast I think it depends on
where you're at - cuz I mean now cuz
it's all global right like like someone
who's let's say affected by Pablo like a
Colombian can see that and be like man
[ __ ] dude [ __ ] Pablo but this isn't
Australia you know it's it's or are they
mad more about the drug use or the Pablo
thing the Colombians getting mad or is
that people in Australia getting mad I
don't know social media that they're
getting mad cuz that would be weird if
they made a North Korean burger and
there's nothing as I said it's just
bread just a plate this is the North
Korean version you get beaten right when
you go in it's all about intent right
like if if you can tell there's humor
behind it then cool but where's it you
Marin this one because it's burger it's
combining Escobar with
there's like they put like they put like
you're serving the coke with the so it's
like do not turn up they don't expect to
give the burger to someone and make
people cry yeah you know it's that's the
intent so even if it was a Nazi
restaurant but there was like some sort
of like every burger had like a little
mustache on it or something like it
could be funny there could be taken a
certain way it's not meant to like cut
someone's feelings in it I think
I think the outrage comes from though
like where this person is known for
doing bad things
mm-hmm this person is known for doing
bad things yeah that person is yeah
that's good party let's open it I'm
gonna make it a juicy burger I guess I
can see like people from but it but it's
like why why why cement this person into
the newer generations of human their
dark humor like that's their choice yeah
so if you don't like it it's cool but
they're not trying to they're not trying
to purposely yeah hurt people yeah
they're not like all we're gonna [ __ ]
we're gonna make people cry today
yeah cuz what would you want to eat
angel burgers like that's not that's
boring us [ __ ] who cares about that [ __ ]
I mean I understand other parodies
because the parodies don't involve
people who are hurt by something all
right so if you put in like I don't know
like a - I know like a two pot taco [ __ ]
cause I think I don't know something
known for that cuz yeah cause like the
the Hitler thing I could see that could
be kind of offensive right down the
street we go to Alondra hot wings and
that place glorifies mob bosses all over
the wall see there's there's yeah
there's mob like this is such old [ __ ]
they like everything like The Sopranos a
godfather and like this is such old [ __ ]
like this has been around people have
been glorifying gangsters and mobsters
for so long though I don't know why
people and these same people probably
never [ __ ] like destroy anything
males to narcos know the [ __ ] are you
doing making a show about this yeah even
though Ted Bundy tapes right now or like
the biopic that they're working on like
before angry about that too because
they're like we should be commemorating
the memory but like remembering the
victims not glorifying Ted Bundy who's
Ted Bundy serial killer killed it was
intimidating and eight people and little
really do wish they make that North
Korean burger I wouldn't laugh my ass
off dumber eight people yeah yeah I
don't know if it's necessarily
glorifying I think it's human nature to
wanna
just be attracted to like [ __ ] like this
and like what just be curious you know
watch the [ __ ] and that's why I think
humans love or [ __ ] like no one actually
wants to go out and kill 50 people
people it's so interesting to see that
someone can do that and then I don't
know like the whole Pablo thing to me I
see it I see that whole thing as a joke
but I also understand that since now
everything is just like I said global
like if someone's family was killed by
Pablo or destroyed by his actions you
know they could really be like man [ __ ]
you don't do that you know this isn't a
joke I could totally see that play out I
guess something that sensitive to the
Chinese community is a Rape of Nanking
we're like the Japanese soldiers came
and just raped them and like cut off
[ __ ] all these Chinese people's dicks
and stuff like that but like let's say
there was a Rape of Nanking parody
noodle shop and all the dumplings just
look like little dick tips that'd be
hilarious but you're also not normal
like you're not the average person
really you don't get offended easily
because I'm like oh it's [ __ ] funny
look call it look they all look like
circumcised dicks over here and I can
just try it and just have a good time
and there's a good theme in there I
think will be pretty funny cuz it's
funny to even combine and combine
something that tragic with the baby
because you didn't live through it and
you didn't see it I don't know if these
people are complaining if they're any of
these the Nazis things too you know yeah
beer you're really good at removing
yourself from it and seeing things for
the nation yeah if the boss was like a
Japanese guy right oh my god and he was
like I mean selling this and goes yeah
you [ __ ] dirty [ __ ] then I'll go
there this guy's kind of mean I'm gonna
why are you live here he's like I am so
racist that I went to China so I could
be racist to Chinese people every day
it's my passion and I'll wait the time
it's all about the intent but the guy's
just like a goofy guy I thought this we
are the restaurant themselves so that
you know the intention here isn't to
offend a lot of Colombians seem to enjoy
it see from then trying to defend
themselves to its part of the kangaroo
[ __ ] arguing our pistons gonna
find it that easily
I know Russians will go [ __ ] all the
Americans I got pissed yeah I saw this
yeah maybe
[Music]